let's get more on that story should we
now standing by for us at gatwick this
morning is uh katie um hi um katie a lot
of people will be wanting to jet away
from this weather uh but uh proving a
little bit more difficult if they've
chosen easy's yet
absolutely not ideal okay for people
wanting to get away for the easter break
now easyjet say they've had to cancel 62
additional flights today uh that's inc
that's
can you hear me kay so i can casey i'm
sorry i don't know what happened there
they have easy jets
no sorry i lost you there for a second
so easyjet says they've cancelled 62
flights today that's in addition to 200
flights that have been cancelled over
the weekend that's because of staff
shortages they say due to
covid due to
the impact of staffing being off sick
with covert they did say they tried to
mitigate the impact of this somewhat by
rostering additional staff on across the
weekend but they have been forced to
cancel these additional flights which
easyjet have said
this morning
they say they've tried to focus the
cancellations on routes with lots of
flights so people are able to re-book
hopefully uh the same day but that's not
what a lot of passengers have been
saying a lot of passengers have been
saying that they've ended up being
stranded their flights have been
cancelled with just hours to spare and
they were offered no alternatives now of
course this is in addition to uh
problems across airports across the uk
we've had issues at heathrow as well
yesterday lots of passengers uh having
extremely long queues there and they
said that was because of high passenger
volumes that they weren't uh necessarily
prepared for also manchester airport
have said uh they have also experienced
staff shortages due to coronavirus again
so a lot of issues with people trying to
get away for the easter holidays and
disruption expected to continue later
into this week
okay thank you thanks a lot
well the independence travel editor
simon cold are standing by for us this
morning hi um simon what on earth is
happening
well we've got yet more cancellations
here as well british airways i'm
counting about 90 cancellations to and
from heathrow its main base of course um
it's pretty much the same problems as
easyjet is facing there's a kind of a
temporary uh serious problem with the
sheer number of people who've got copied
as you've been reporting and that means
that an awful lot of crew are sick that
explains why we've had not just
cancellations that were notified maybe a
couple of days even a couple of weeks in
advance we've had a whole slew of
cancellations of british airway flights
overnight as well
um that is kind of on top of the more
profound chronic problem which is that
eating jet british airways
heathrow airport gatwick manchester
edinburgh bristol belfast they've all
let great staff go over the past couple
of years when aviation
almost closed down and unfortunately you
cannot just switch back on
that amount of people that amount of
expertise they've got to be trained
they've got to be security cleared and
while there's a huge demand for people
wanting to travel for an awful lot of
families of course it's the first
holiday they've been able to have uh for
a couple of years um unfortunately the
airlines can't cope really crucially k
we were hearing about passengers not
being rebuilt it is absolutely clear if
your flight is cancelled then the
airline is obliged to book you on the
next available flight doesn't matter if
they've got to buy a business class
ticket on a different airline that's
what they need to do to get you to your
destination they also need to pay you
cash compensation and of course if you
need to stay overnight they will be
booking your hotel and paying for your
meals that's absolutely strict liability
and they can't get around it i'm hearing
very sadly the number of passengers
saying that they're not delivering that
um the airlines say oh yes we do so
as long as you know what your rights are
you can try to insist on them
yeah it doesn't stop spoiling your
holiday though um does it um what's
happening at manchester airport
okay manchester's got pretty chronic
problems of course the biggest uh
airport in the whole of the north of
britain um
just behind heathrow and catholic in
terms of passenger numbers and well
again they haven't got the security
staff um there's big problems and they
they tried to open terminal one attempt
three that hasn't happened so just very
very long queues where i flying out of
um manchester or stansted already i
think i would invest four thousand five
pounds or six pounds respectively in
fast track security and to try to avoid
those problems um it has been really bad
over the weekend it should be a little
bit easier at the moment but i'm afraid
as with so much in travel you can hope
for the best years to holidays but be
prepared for delays and disruption